[Music]  blood toil  tears and sweat but no evasion  for more than a year alessandra and her  company have been dancing to an empty  auditorium  with no audience to dazzle people  performing arts are slowly reopening  like here at the teatro nazionali  the european parliament recognizes that  culture is essential for education  democracy and a sense of belonging it's  helping artists and performers bounce  back  with the 2.5 billion euro creative  europe program  europa grade fundamental  union  [Music]  with the biggest budget ever for the  eu's cultural and audio-visual sectors  meps want help to go to projects which  have european  added value parliament also wants  creative europe to promote female talent  and become more accessible to all kinds  of public like the disabled and socially  marginalized  mep's obtained a special focus on and  support  for the music industry which was hit  particularly hard by the pandemic